Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode Live.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, but you may
know me as Rawkode. Go figure.
We've got a really cool episode today. We're
taking a look at a tool to help
make your Kubernetes lives easier.
Who doesn't want that, right?
We're gonna be taking a look at Lens
from Marantus,
but before we do that, we've got a
little bit of housekeeping.
So
I say this every week. If you're not
subscribed to the channel, now is the time
to do so. Please subscribe and click that
bell. You will get notifications for all new
episodes of Rawkode Live.
I'm gonna do my best to produce materials
to help us navigate this vast cloud native
landscape together, and I would appreciate you joining,
engaging,
chatting in the comments, and having some fun.
We also have a Discord server. Feel free
to join at rockload.chat.
There's nearly 500 of us in there now
talking about all things cloud native and Kubernetes.
So come and say hello, and I look
forward to meeting you.
Also, there are Rawkode membership packages from as
low as 99p
per month to support this channel,
and also there is incubating and graduating levels.
Incubating is for people that wanna join us
and do live courses and workshops. Currently, are
working through a course on influx DB two.
We had an episode today where we explored
the Flux language and how to query time
series data.
I wanna thank Kevin who signed up today
for incubating level and Noel who has already
been in there, and there's a few other
of you. Remember to join the Discord and
connect your YouTube
Alright. That is the housekeeping done. We are
going to meet Edward from the Lens team
at MERANTIS. Hey, man. How's it going?
It's going well, David. Thank you. Thank you
for having me today. How are you? Very
well. Today has been a good day, and
I'm excited to to play with Lens. I
always like it when I get a tool
that I played with and I enjoy and
then get to learn more about it today.
So this is gonna be an awesome episode.
Awesome.
I'm looking forward to it.
Do you wanna take a minute and just
for anyone who's not familiar with you and
Mirantis and Lens, just give us a little
bit of an introduction, please?
Absolutely. Absolutely. So first off, I wanna thank
you for having me here today and the
audience. Hello. I'm Edward Ianell, and I'm part
of the team.
I'm specifically on the product team, and I'm
focused on open source technologies
like Lens and k zero s, which is
a lightweight Kubernetes distro.
And,
more of my day to day responsibilities
is
really
seeking out the pain points within Kubernetes and
other cloud native technologies to help and try
to streamline developer and operator initiatives when working
with these technologies.
So, that's my main focus, and Lens is
something that I actually stumble up upon prior
to even being a part of the Lens
team while I was at Marantus.
And we acquired,
the Lens and the team of Lens,
back in August of last year. And I
was using the tool before we even acquired
them. And once
I, we acquired them, I was begging to
join the team actually. So this was something
I wanted to do quite a lot, and
this is how I got this cool little
Lens hoodie, which, people are able to get
if they would like to join our Slack
channel. I'm always giving away free hoodies. So
again, David, thanks for having me. Looking forward
to this wonderful session.
Awesome. Great.
Introduction.
Yeah. People get in the Slack channel. Get
yourself a hoodie because those are pretty sweet.
Alright.
I believe you're gonna start us off with
some slides to talk about what Lens is
and why people should be interested in it,
and then we're gonna do a hands on
demo.
You wanna Absolutely. Get your screen up and
we'll kick this thing off.
Sounds good. And let me know if you
can see my screen.
Yes. I see the Kubernetes IDE five. All
yours, Edward. Awesome. Well, again, thank you, David.
So
hello, everyone. I'm looking forward to this awesome
session. And as David mentioned, we will be
doing two things. One, we'll take a look
at these slides. It's just an overview for
us to get a better understanding of what
Lens IDE,
some of the features that are within the
IDE,
and why developers or operators should be utilizing
this open source technology.
From there, we'll transition into a live demo
where we'll go through the key features,
as well as what a developer may use
Lens for, an operator may use Lens for,
an SRE may be using Lens for. And
then after that, we'll actually take a look
at something that's quite cool, and it was
released with our newest release, which is Lens
five. We released that back in June of
this year, and we'll be taking a look
at how you can share access
to a Kubernetes cluster securely
through Lens Spaces.
So that's another exciting thing that we'll be
taking a look at today.
So without further ado, let's jump straight into
it. I know this is going to be
a jam packed session. And, thank you all
for joining us today. I'm quite excited about
this one.
So we can skip over this slide. We
already talked about it, but, again, responsible for
growth and developer relations here at Orantis.
We'll skip through this slide.
So I'm sure we all know this already,
but I'll just touch on it a little
bit. Kubernetes is quite challenging.
People, organizations invest in Kubernetes and other cloud
native technologies,
but they may not be seeing that return
on investment that they should when working with
containers or Kubernetes.
This is kind of where Lens comes in.
Lens is a 100%
open source technology. That's a developer friendly desktop
application
meant for all of your Kubernetes needs. It
works with any certified Kubernetes distro,
whether that is GKE,
EKS,
k zeros, k three s, mini queue, and
so forth.
I did wanna bring some stats up. The
these are roughly a month old or so
as you guys can or two months old,
actually.
But we are the self proclaimed, and I
I like to mention that we are the
self proclaimed world's most popular Kubernetes
IDE.
Currently,
on GitHub, we have 15,000
GitHub stargazers,
which is a fantastic
achievement from the team. And I do want
to thank the community for this. We cannot
be at this pace and at this level
of, GitHub stargazers
without the amazing cloud native ecosystem and the
community that we're all within.
We also have 250,000
users that are using the the tool itself,
and we have roughly 80,000
people using it daily.
And we've seen over a 60,000
different clusters in the last thirty days, and
we always have some telemetry to be able
to tell us, what type of clusters people
are using.
So
before moving on,
into the demo itself, where you are going
to take a look at the features at
a glance, I'm going to talk to these
slides. I do want to mention that these
are just some of the features that we
will be presenting in the slide deck itself,
but we'll be taking a look at many
different things that, you can do within Lens
once you have that desktop application downloaded and
installed on your operating system.
Excellent. So the first one is a unified
catalog.
The unified catalog should be thought of as
a cloud native directory, at least that's what
I like to think of it as, where
you can bring your clusters, your services, your
workloads, tools that you may be using in
one beautiful place,
which makes it a directory. Users of Lens
can actually
very easily filter between these different resources
and, assign labels to these resources to really
easily recall what type of resource that particular
asset may be, whether it's a Kubernetes cluster
or a new Lens space or a web
link,
and so forth. And we'll touch on some
of these things actually in the demo itself.
So that's the catalog. I think of it
as a cloud native directory.
The next thing are two very useful things
to improve efficiency
when working with Lens and Kubernetes,
of course. So the first is the hotbar,
which is going to be on the left
hand side of the Lens desktop application,
and this should be thought of as, like,
the main navigation of Lens. And what I
use the hotbar for is to really create
specific workflows
within my environment within Lens. I can have
different spaces, and spaces are,
collaborative spaces where you can add Kubernetes clusters
to and share that with your team. Talk
about that more in a second, where I
can add my clusters to the hotbar itself.
So I can easily navigate from cluster to
cluster regardless of the Kubernetes distro.
And,
we have the command palette, which is, another
great resource to work much more efficiently within
Lens. The command palette should be thought of
as or it is keyboard shortcuts to perform
specific actions. Right? So for example, adding a
cluster to Lens,
viewing viewing a specific pod when you're within
a cluster, you can use a quick shortcut
to be able to actually access this particular
item or feature or whatever you may be
doing very, very quickly. So these are two
things that help our users work much more
efficiently when leveraging Kubernetes.
The hotbar, and it's the command palette.
So this is actually one of my favorite
features within Lens, and it's,
I call it the pre built in Prometheus.
Lens
automagically
yeah. I used automagically.
It's new word I'm using, David. So
so Lens automagically,
allows you to leverage a prebuilt in Prometheus
directly into your cluster, meaning I can very
easily see how my cluster is performing in
the last hour from the CPU to the
memory,
the disk, and so forth. And I can
also see the total nodes,
the total capacity, the actual usage that I'm
using, and that, again, is all in the
last hour, and it's a very granular view.
So we'll take a look at this,
in just a bit.
The next thing, and this is actually probably
my favorite feature within Lens because I find
it to be the most useful, and this
is the smart terminal.
The smart terminal is is quite important,
to to our users and myself. And the
reason for this is within Lens, you may
be working with
many different clusters.
Right? So I could be working with five,
ten, 15, even 30 different clusters and more.
And I need to be able to always
match to the correct Kubernetes cluster endpoint. Right?
That the API endpoint of that cluster. So
when I switch from cluster to cluster,
Lens automatically,
matches to the correct cluster API endpoint,
which is so important. Right? Because if I'm
switching from cluster to cluster,
I know that I'm connected to that correct
Kubernetes endpoint when working with that cluster. So
this is extremely useful when working with multiple
Kubernetes clusters, maybe a production cluster, development cluster,
or even different distros.
You can be assured
that you are always in the correct
cluster endpoint, right, that you're always matching to
that correct cluster API version,
which is extremely important. Another thing I wanna
mention is that Lens always
automatically connects to the correct kubectl
and helm
sticking to that correct version,
within the terminal itself, which is a fantastic
feature as well. And we'll take a look
at these things in the demo.
So the next one,
another one of my favorite features probably, maybe
third three or four down the list, when
it comes to my favorite, but, this is
being able to deploy Helm charts very easily.
So Lens has
the ability to view thousands of publicly available
made Helm charts,
and you can manage these directly in your
cluster. Meaning, I can deploy a Helm chart
directly to my cluster in a matter of
seconds,
maybe
yeah. Or in in the matter of seconds
with one or two different clicks.
So this is extremely useful, when viewing different
Helm charts or trying to deploy them directly
onto your cluster, and we will actually be
doing that today as well. We'll take a
look at some Helm charts, the Helm charts
that are available.
We'll, we'll install a Helm chart directly to
our cluster.
And, depending on the Helm chart itself, we
may even port forward into the application.
Extensions.
So this is my second favorite feature,
and there's a couple reasons why. So extensions
are,
plugins built directly on top of Lens.
And the reason why this is so valuable
is, let's say, for example, that,
I am a startup within the cloud native
ecosystem,
and I
have built a product tool or service that
is able to tell me vulnerabilities
within a Kubernetes cluster.
So that startup organization and so forth can
build a plug in on top of Lens
where they can leverage our users, or our
users can leverage that technology
to be able to very easily understand the
vulnerabilities
within that cluster itself.
Right? So it's twofold. One, our users get
to leverage new technologies,
and two, our partners and the community and
the the ecosystem
can leverage our users to get up and
running very quickly if their product service open
source technology is brand new. Right? So currently,
we have over a hundred different extensions built
on top of Lens. Many of these I
do wanna mention are not publicly available,
but we do have 10 or 15 different
publicly available extensions made
for the community. Some are built by Team
Lens, and others are built by awesome,
partner technologies
and companies like Aqua Security,
Kubernetes,
QCost,
and so forth. So we'll take a look
at some of these extensions as well towards
the end of the hands on demo.
And lastly,
spaces. I touched on this just slightly when
we were taking a look at the unified
catalog,
and spaces should be thought of as a
centralized cloud based offering on top of Lens.
Really, what it allows our users to do
is build collaborative
spaces
where you can add specific Kubernetes clusters to
that space,
and then you can invite a teammate member
or a colleague
to that space, and they will be able
to have specific,
access to whatever's within that space. Currently, it
only works for,
excuse me, Kubernetes clusters,
but we do have some exciting different things
we will be releasing,
in the road map and in the future.
So, that's important to keep in mind. But
long story short,
Lens Spaces allows Kubernetes cluster admins to share
access to their Kubernetes cluster securely.
Well, excellent. We took a look at many
different features already from the unified catalog,
the hotbar,
the command palette, the pre built in Prometheus,
deploying helm charts,
extensions,
and of course, Lens spaces.
From here, I think we're actually going to
transition directly into the demo itself, where we'll
take a look at Lens,
how to get started,
some of the cool features in action.
And then if we have time towards the
end, we actually will share a Kubernetes cluster
with David today,
and it should be an exciting session. So
once again, I wanna thank you, David, for
having me and the audience with us today.
I'm looking forward to this to this demo,
and, hopefully, nothing breaks, you know, in in
live sessions that can happen. But I have
a feeling I have a feeling it won't
happen to us today. So without further ado,
let's jump directly into the hands on demo
where we'll be taking a look at Lens,
the Kubernetes IDE.
I don't wanna worry you, Edward, but, I
mean, I just look at clusters and they
break. I'm just I'm just saying.
Yes. Yes. And and they do break and
they do break, and let's hope nothing breaks
now. I've I've been taking a look at
some of my clusters.
So,
everyone, this is Lens. Whoops.
This is Lens here. And, David, you still
can see my screen. Correct? We can. Yeah.
Excellent.
So this is Lens. When you're first brought
into Lens, you're actually brought into that catalog
screen that that we talked about about that
cloud native directory where you can bring different
tools, clusters,
web links, spaces to
to be able to very easily filter and
manage all your different cloud native resources.
Currently, there's only a couple of things supported,
and I do wanna mention that the catalog
was released,
back in June of this year.
But we do plan on releasing
many other resources that can fit within the
catalog, like specific automations
and tools,
that our users can leverage.
Right now, we have our spaces.
And, again, that's that centralized cloud based offering
that allows us to share access to Kubernetes
cluster securely.
We have our web links within our within
our catalog as well. Anything can be added
here. So one of the things I like
to do since I'm I'm not the most
advanced Kubernetes user, I'm I'm not a novice
either,
but, I like to have, like, a Qt
CTL cheat sheet.
So,
you guys can see that here. And just
since we're talking about it real quick, if
I click this icon here in the hot
bar, I'm immediately brought up to this Kubernetes
cheat sheet,
right,
which is which is quite powerful. And this
one's built by Mirantis, but there's many others
that I leverage as well, within the ecosystem.
And there's some fantastic
ones built by many different companies and developers
and so forth.
So, I like to utilize a cheat sheet
depending on the activity that I'm doing.
And again, those are the web links.
Then we have our clusters within our catalog
as well. All of these different clusters,
and we can see within the source
column,
we can see that some of these clusters
are local, and some are attached to Lendspaces.
We'll talk about the clusters that are attached
to Lendspaces
a little bit more in just a moment.
From here, what I really want to do
is actually begin taking a look at the
true functionality behind Lens. The catalog is fantastic
when trying to access different resources,
but the true power behind Lens is the
full situational awareness that you get when working
with Kubernetes clusters.
So on the left hand side, we can
see my hotbar here. I have a k
zeros cluster.
We don't see any Prometheus here as of
right now, and the reason for this is
I have not checked the box to have
the prebuilt in Prometheus launch on this cluster,
but we we will do this. Then I
have my mini cube cluster,
right, where that's when you can actually see
the prebuilt in Prometheus.
We can see how it's performing in the
last hour from the CPU to the memory,
the total capacity, the number of pods. And
here at the bottom of this overview screen,
we can always see real time events that
are pushed to us as a user.
Right? So we can see if there's any,
problems, if we need to debug an object
and so forth right here in this spot.
Then we also have our GKE cluster. Again,
it's missing
the Prometheus configuration,
which is absolutely fine. We will actually install
it and push it directly onto our cluster
in just a moment.
And then here, I do wanna mention that
this is a demo cluster built by some
of our, team members here at MERANTIS, and
this cluster is shared with me. So this
is not my cluster. I did not add
it to Lens itself.
This is just a cluster that's shared with
me through Lens Spaces, which is quite, quite
cool.
That being said, let's actually take a look
at how you can add a cluster to
Lens. So if you navigate to your catalog,
click clusters,
there will be a plus icon here.
In this plus icon,
there's two ways to add a cluster. Only
really one way for the user to do
it, but Lens actually automatically searches
for a QConfig file on your operating system,
and it will add that cluster directly to
Lens without you having to do anything once
you hit that plus icon, of course.
Or you can copy the q config file
directly into this,
let's call it a terminal, and you can
add the clusters.
So those are the two ways to add
clusters directly to Lens.
Going back to my k zeros cluster, let's
actually jump into the settings here.
Right clicking on the hotbar icon will bring
us to our settings,
and we have several different,
functions that we can perform. So the first
thing is we can always give it a
name, which for this demonstration, I'm just calling
it what it is, which is a k
zero s cluster.
And we can give it an icon. And
the reason why this is awesome, and we
touched on this a little bit, in the
slide deck, but it's that efficiency aspect. Right?
Being able to navigate from cluster to cluster
very easily just by an icon. So as
we can see, we can see this is
a k zero. We can see this is
the Mini Cube logo, and here's a GKD
cluster as well. Going back to our settings,
we are actually gonna drop down to the
Lens metrics,
and we're gonna add the metrics directly to
our cluster by doggling these doggles here.
Click apply,
and this is where something may break. Let's
hope not, but, I'm I'm sure it's gonna
be fine. We have multiple different Kubernetes clusters
here already. So, even if something did happen,
which I highly doubt it will, but even
if something did, we can always switch to
a different cluster. Right? And then take a
look at,
all of the features from that cluster itself.
So let's just close this here.
Go to nodes.
Let's see if it begins to actually add
the pre built in Prometheus slowly but surely.
It may take a while to do this
since it's actually installing it.
So it did not wanna do it. Let's
see what's going on here.
Maybe if we come back to it in
just a second. Let's see.
We'll go to settings one more time. Let's
just take a look at what's happening.
We have auto detect. Yes.
And then Lensmetrics.
They're toggled. Okay.
Generally, I think this takes a couple minutes
to do, which is absolutely fine. But from
here, we'll just jump into our Minikube cluster.
Now within our Minikube cluster, we do have
that prebuilt in Prometheus directly pushed to our
cluster. And as mentioned, we can see how
it's performing in the last hour.
On the bottom, this plus icon, you can
do two very cool functions. You can open
up a terminal session, which is that smart
terminal that we mentioned already, where it automagically
matches to the correct cluster endpoint. So if
I write kubectl
git nodes,
you can see the version.
Right?
Kubectl
version.
You can see the git version. And if
I switch to my k zeros cluster,
and there's the Prometheus as we can see.
So it just took a couple minutes to
do. Right?
If we switch to my k zeros cluster,
we can see it's connecting to the correct
endpoint,
and we can see it's a different Git
version. Right? So whenever we're navigating
to a new cluster,
it's automatically doing this on its own. So
we are reducing user error here when switching
from cluster to cluster, and you can see
it's different for our GKD cluster as well.
So that's the smart terminal, and it's extremely
important to note that Lens and we'll be
taking a look at this in a moment.
But Lens is always leveraging
your role based access control from your QConfig
file. If you do not have the correct
permissions from your QConfig file, those particular
functions and things that you may want to
do to your cluster that you will be
unable to do.
So let's move on from here.
We have our nodes. Again, we can view
our nodes, how they're performing in the last
hour from the CPU to the memory, the
disk, the pods, and so forth,
and we get all of the details associated
to this particular object. Right? So we have
our labels. We have the operating system. We
have the OS image. We have the kernel
version. We have the container runtime,
the cubelet version, and, of course, the capacity
and all of the pods that are associated
to this node as well. Right, which is
extremely
useful for one debugging
or just trying to navigate through your cluster
very easily without having to write any KubeCTL.
Right? So I know many developers that like
to take this route or even operators, SREs
that like to take this route because it's
going to save them a lot of time
instead of always having to write, within the
CLI
different command lines and so forth.
So if I chose to do so, I
can actually click into one of these pods.
And, again, we're given a granular view of
how that particular pod is performing in the
last hour with all of the details necessary
again.
From here, I do wanna highlight some of
the functions that you can perform within Lens
as well, again, based off of your RBAC.
Right? We're always leveraging your RBAC for your
Kubernetes cluster. So we can shell into the
node.
We can the node. We can drain the
node. And, of course, we can edit this
resource, right, if we choose to do so
hitting that pencil icon. We can begin configuring,
debugging, and making changes here if we choose
to do so,
which is quite, quite awesome. So we'll close
this again. And, of course, we can delete
it, which is something I don't want to
do for for for all honestly.
But that that is something we can do
as well. From here, we'll transition to our
workloads, and we get an overview screen here
as well.
You can see your pods, your deployments, your
staple sets, and so forth. I wanna mention
that these green,
color code that we see is good. So,
typically, if something was wrong with our cluster
or within one of these objects, whether it's
a pod, a deployment, and so forth, we'll
actually have different color codes throughout this sphere.
So we can have,
maybe running with, say, 12, and then it
would say warning message one,
for example, on the pods.
Currently, we do not have any of those,
which is fantastic. I know this cluster is
performing fun. And on the bottom here, and
this is actually one of my favorite extensions
ever built, and it's built by one of
our developers here at, Orion, this is Team
Lens specifically.
And this is something we'll take a look
at in just a bit as well,
when we get to the extensions
side. But this is a beautiful extension that
allows us to see how all of our
Kubernetes resources and objects are related to one
another. Right? So zooming in, we can see
our Prometheus,
everything that it's associated with, and then, of
course, we can get details
into this config map, the namespace,
and so forth. And then clicking on it
gives us that granular view again,
of that object
deployment pod, whatever it may be.
Right? Yeah. That resource topology map is pretty
sweet. I like that. It's it's awesome. Right?
And you know what's so cool about it
too is when you're working with, a massive
cluster.
Right? I mean, this is this is a
smaller cluster, but when you're working with a
massive cluster and being able to see how
how everything's,
connected and,
and with all the objects and resources, it's
absolutely awesome. So, yeah, I love this one
as well. It's actually my favorite currently made,
available extension,
and I I leverage it all the time.
So from here, we'll click into pods. There's
several ways to do so. You can do
it from the overview screen or you can
click pods here, and it immediately gives us
this beautiful,
user interface
where we can filter very quickly. So again,
if this is a massive cluster with, let's
say, 50 to a hundred different pods, for
example, we can very easily navigate,
based off of the filters here. I do
wanna mention these filters are very similar to,
like, Excel, for example, or Google Sheets, where
if you have a filter going, so if
I'm gonna filter by default namespaces,
this will actually follow us everywhere throughout Lens.
So it's very important to notice and
know this is happening.
When I first was using Lens,
I I swear to you guys,
I had it filtered for one of these
different namespaces,
and I thought I was going in going
in insane
searching for other deployments and pods and so
forth because it was filtered down by the
namespace. So I do wanna mention that, you
do need to uncheck the filter as you
navigate through
Lens.
It's quite important to mention. Again, you can
also search for specific pods here.
You can view the status and so forth.
And the reason why, again, this is so
valuable is if you have a massive cluster,
you have to perform various different command lines
to view all of your objects
within your cluster. So I just ran a
quick command line, and now we can see,
all of the different objects within our cluster.
Right?
Very, very easily when they were created, when
they're running. But then, again, if you wanna
view a specific object,
you would have to run another command line
to access that that that object as well.
Right? Compared to with Lens, I can just
click directly into this controller.
I can view the metrics immediately of this
pod, see how it's performing, again, from CPU,
memory, network, etcetera. And then, again, I have
very various different functions that I can perform
as well. Like, I can show them to
the pod. I can view the logs, which
is a fantastic resource. You can search through
the logs. You can actually download the logs
as well. You can share them with a
colleague, for example,
and so forth.
Right?
And again,
you can edit that resource directly within Lens.
Right? And that's what makes it that IDE
is being able to to edit these resources.
One thing I do wanna showcase
before moving on is,
the ability to create a resource directly into
our cluster here. So when I click this
icon, we actually have some cool templates that
you can leverage right off the bat. So,
we can do a deployment. This will deploy
an NGINX deployment directly into Lens
as you guys can see, and I can
create it and close it, and it immediately
deploys this resource directly into our deployments.
I've deployed this already, so that's why you
can see the date is four days ago.
And the neat thing about Lens is we
really do leverage Kubernetes
to to scale our different workloads and our
deployments. Right? So I'm using the user interface
here to actually scale this deployment up, so
I can scale it up to, like, let's
say, 30.
And if I jump to my pods,
we begin creating all of these different,
containers,
right, all in real time. And, of course,
this is Kubernetes doing this.
Right? But we're just using the user interface
without having to write any command line to
scale this up, which I think is, quite
quite valuable.
So that's a very neat feature as well.
And if I jump back to my deployments,
I'll grab this NGINX.
It's still processing,
and here's that resource map that we can
see that's going crazy right now.
But these are all those deployments, and they're
the same deployment. So four, very, very cool.
And, again, we see all of the details
associated to this deployment. I'm gonna scale this
back down.
My machine is screaming at me right now.
So we'll scale it back down.
And if we scroll down, we begin terminating
these containers,
right, all in real time.
Can I ask a question?
Absolutely.
So, I mean, this is really cool. Right?
And been able to navigate through pods, deployment,
Steven sets, people sets, all of that. Like,
that's probably 80%
of what I need to do. But what
about custom resources?
Does Lens
understand custom resources? Now let me center out
with those with the same kind of nice
visual UI?
Absolutely. Yes. So we do have custom resources
here. I don't have any
added to my cluster, but you absolutely can
bring in, like, for example, like, Istio or
something along the lines of that directly to
your cluster. So I don't have any on
this cluster, but, yes, to answer your question,
you can.
K. We also have a question from the
chat if you want that just now, or
do you wanna wait?
Sure. What is it? Russell
is asking,
what filtering does a log view have? Can
I use a regex to search?
One more time. I'm sorry. I missed that,
David. Russell wants to know from the log
view on the pause, do we have the
ability to filter those logs, and can I
use regular expressions to filter that if needed?
I believe so. Yes. I I do believe
so.
Let's take a look here.
Maybe wrong, but I believe you can, actually.
I think maybe the search at the top
right.
Yep. There it is. Yep.
So if you just type tools, does that
okay. So it's like a highlight kind of
search. Got it. Okay. Yeah.
That makes sense.
Awesome.
Let's close this.
And,
so as you guys saw, we just deployed
a resource directly into,
our cluster as well, which was the NGINX
deployment.
We scaled that up leveraging leveraging Lens.
So couple of things we've taken a look
at already. Right? That multi cluster management tool.
Right? Switching from cluster to cluster while always
maintaining the correct Kubernetes endpoint, extremely important when
working with many different clusters.
We took a look at the pre built
in Prometheus that allows us to understand how
our cluster's performing in the last hour from
the CPU to the memory,
the nodes, the pods, the capacity. And here,
we have a we have a warning message
as I talked about earlier. So if I
open this up, it's going to give us
details
on this particular object,
excuse me, which is a pod.
Scrolling down, we can see the events and
the more warning message here.
Right? So this is gonna help us debug,
troubleshoot, and so forth,
within this particular object.
Then we can, of course, view the logs
and go from there.
We also took a look at accessing
various different objects,
one object to the other. We deployed a
resource.
We looked at the Prometheus.
And from here, we're gonna transition into actually
taking a look at the helm charts,
the extensions,
and then we will also
create a new space, add a cluster to
that space, share that space with David, and
he'll be able to see that cluster as
well.
So from here, to be able to access
your,
Helm charts or down in this app section,
you click charts,
and then it'll immediately
start bringing up all of the charts and
the repos it's associated to. So I I
do wanna mention that,
my current
Lens desktop application, the way it's set up
is I'm only going after certain repos as
you guys can see here. And to do
to change this, I believe you go to
preferences.
Let's see.
Yes. And then here within this Helm chart
section,
you can add a custom Helm repo, or
you can add, you know, from the thousands
of repos that are publicly made available here.
Right?
I only use certain ones. So I use
Morentis.
I use Bitnami. I use Stable, and that's
really it. This Cloudflare one, I don't even
think I use. So I can remove that,
and then we can navigate back to our
applications or our Helm charts, and we can
search for particular helm charts as well. Right?
So if I wanna deploy a WordPress helm
chart,
you click here.
It's immediately going to give me all details
associated
to this chart itself.
Right? Who's maintaining it,
where it lives, keywords it's associated with, and,
of course, how to get started with this
home chart. If you even chose to do
this,
on your own, right, without deploying it through
Lens, like, you can do it to the
terminal or command line and so forth.
Scrolling back up,
we're gonna install the sound chart.
Let's actually close this pod stuff out.
And this usually takes a couple minutes as
well just as we did with the Prometheus
that we saw on the k zeros cluster.
Some details.
You can make some changes here if you
chose to do so.
We'll click install.
And
it's been installed to our cluster. So several
ways to access it, you can view the
release here.
And we can see all of the resources
that were created for this Helm chart, the
service accounts, the secrets, the config map, and
so forth.
Right?
So so that's very awesome to see. Another
thing I wanna point out is actually the
ability
to,
port forward directly into this application.
So this should work fine,
I imagine.
Just a second.
So if I chose to put forward into
it,
It's taking longer than usual.
Yeah. I was wondering if that that delay
was normal or if it was just having
a wee spending problem to itself there.
Yeah. It's it's not normal, actually. I wonder
if
my computer is just going crazy.
Still to cover them from those 30 pods
you spun up, I think. Yeah. Exactly.
The the mini q cluster, it is it
doesn't like it. So let's give it one
more try. Let's see if we can get
into this port.
Come on.
Def the longest it's taken. That's fine. Let's
actually
this won't work. I doubt it. Yeah. But,
unfortunately, it's not working here, everybody.
Part of the live demo. Right?
But,
you can port forward directly into the application
also on BLNs. What you would do is
you go to services.
That's
why.
I don't think it's got any endpoint yet.
Yeah. Exactly.
And so forth. So,
anyways,
that is port forwarding, and that is in
installing a Helm chart directly to our to
our app to our cluster. Are the pods
running yet?
Let's take a look.
So we have some problems. Unbound immediate persistent
volume claims. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So so we're having some
problems here as you guys can see, and
then we get that message that's,
that's directly built into our into into Lens
as well. Scrolling scrolling down, we can see
a little bit more about it. Zero to
one nodes are available. One pod has unbound
immediate
volume claims.
So, again, if you chose to troubleshoot this,
you have the ability to do so,
relatively quickly, and I think this is another
reason why,
we weren't able to pull forward. But that
being said, let's not troubleshoot this right now.
There it goes. But it it doesn't work
because as David mentioned, there's no endpoint currently.
You should be able to pull forward to
that NGINX one, though, if you wanna do
that instead. Let's give that a shot. Yeah.
Let's go to deployments.
But, actually, we'll go to services.
Whoops.
Where did you go?
Oh, it's just part okay. It's just a
deployment. There's no service for it.
Yeah. That's what it's exactly.
It's still trying to open that for after
I clicked all of those things. That's funny.
Excellent. So we talked a little bit about
home charts, but now let's take a look
at
our
oh, we had a crash, guys.
That'll be the last time you spin up
30 pods on your own machine.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. And in a in
a live demo as well. So we're we're
gonna get away from this mini cube cluster
for now. We'll go back to my case
zeros cluster and stay away from that. So
now let's talk about extensions.
And, currently, I have one extension added to
this Kubernetes cluster, which is the resource map.
To add extensions,
very simple. You click Lens on the top
and left side, click extensions,
and you would
install the extensions that are available
to publicly available, or you can bring your
own as well. So here are some extensions
that are publicly available. We have Moreintas container
cloud extension,
which, allows you to connect,
your MCC
infra,
and your Morantis Kubernetes engine cluster directly to
Lens without actually having to add that QConfig
file or have Lens search for it on
your operating system. You have the starboard extension
by Aqua Security.
This is an amazing extension that shows you
vulnerabilities
within your cluster as, within your cluster,
and you have several different, fun ones as
well. One of the funnest ones, but I
haven't used in a long time. Yeah. I
said funnest, but, it's space invaders.
You can actually kill pods
through this game. I don't know if it's
been updated in a while, so it may
not work. But let's actually,
grab it and download it and see
if,
we can spin this up in our cluster.
Again, I haven't used this in a while,
and I know we don't really maintain this
one. It was more of an experiment.
So going here, we can search for it.
Look for our downloads.
Let's just grab the name Lens app. Okay.
No memory. There it is. Space Invaders.
And then it'll begin installing to our desktop
application.
You can see it was successfully installed,
and we get a status that it's incompatible.
So it has not been updated in quite
some time. So I'm gonna uninstall this, but
we'll take a look at that resource map
that is already installed,
directly to our desktop application,
which, is something we took a look at
earlier.
So I'll just touch on this just one
more time here,
since we talked about it already.
But here's our Kubernetes resource manifest, which will
show us how all of our objects and
resources,
are connected to one another. And, of course,
you can get the details.
You could hover over them and view them.
And then, again, you can click directly into
them,
right, and get that much more granular view
of that particular resource. So the stateful set
Prometheus,
the CPU, all the way to the file
system.
Right? And, of course, we can jump into
this resource and make some configuration changes as
well.
So
many things we've covered already,
and the last thing I really wanna try
to
get into this demo is Lenspaces,
which is our
newest,
feature and release brought to Lens, and it's
actually a very, very cool release. Again, it's
a centralized cloud based offering that allows cluster
admins
the ability to create these secure spaces
that allows you to share access to a
Kubernetes cluster.
So you're not giving anybody access to your
KubeConfig.
You're actually just giving them access to the
cluster. And, initially, it's just like a read
only.
Right? And then you would actually have to
change the role bindings and and the roles
within that cluster and that QConfig file to
give them further access. So for example, if
I wanted to give developers,
access to a Kubernetes cluster, maybe they want
a few logs of a microservice or something
along these lines, they can do so once
you make a little bit of changes
to the kube config.
So from here, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create a space. I'll
click this plus icon.
We're gonna call it Rawkode.
Good name.
Not create space.
Ah, I know why.
It's because I have too many spaces.
Let's go to my profile, spaces.
We can leave that one,
and we'll leave this one as well.
K. Now let's create a new space.
Could not create space.
Is it because my username is Rawkode?
No. No. I I don't think so. Let's
try.
I think it has to do with,
how many spaces and clusters I've shared.
Let's try IoT.
Wow.
Maybe it does have something to do with
your with your username. I'm gonna have to
take that back to the team and and
see exactly what happened here,
because that is a little bit alarming.
Anyways,
now that we've created our space, what we
can do is we can actually add our
cluster directly to this space. So if I
take this Minikube cluster, I can share it,
and we can share it to this IoT
space.
Here, what we need to do is we
actually need to install cluster connect directly to
our cluster. This creates an end to end
encrypted
tunneling between,
the cluster and the API itself. So clicking
here, install cluster and share.
So we've added that to our cluster.
Now what I actually have to do is
I need to invite David to this space,
and then he'll be able to see the
space and have some,
access to that Kubernetes cluster. Again, it's read
only initially.
You would have to alter the role binding,
and the R back to be able to
actually give him further access to that to
that cluster itself.
It's quite secure. So Could we have a
a question on that in the chat if
you're happy to Sure. Sure. So Russell
asking,
is the authentication mechanism using RBAC or something
else entirely?
So I think what Russell is asking there
is when we install
ClusterConnect,
is it creating
an RBAC, a role and a service account?
It is. Okay.
It is. Yes. It absolutely is. So now
we'll click.
This is you, correct, David? I believe it
is. Well, I'll ask you. That is me.
That's me.
And we'll click share cluster.
So I've sent you the invite,
and what I will do now is I
will actually stop sharing, and if you can
begin sharing,
Lens and your screen, and we can go
from there.
Done.
So jumping back.
Stop sharing. You know, I almost clicked hang
up. That was a close
Wouldn't be the first time.
I can see your screen.
You
said it wouldn't be the first time? Yeah.
I've been hung up on before and not
intentionally. Of course. Of course. But I That's
that's funny. So from here, what you'll have
to do actually is you'll navigate to the
Rawk on the bottom right. You're using it,
and you'll click my profile.
And here, you'll click spaces,
and then you should see an invitation to
that space.
Once you accept that invitation,
you can navigate back to your catalog
where that space now lives in that, like,
directory that we mentioned,
and just clicking that x icon at the
top right will allow you to do so.
It created a default space of my username.
I think that Yeah. That explains why That
is what
happened. That is what happened. Yes. Yes. Yes.
That is what happened.
And then catalog exactly.
And
there you can see those clusters.
Right? The Lenspace cluster
from here. And it looks like it added,
your own clusters already,
to to Lens. At at least that's what
it looks like. So clicking that,
and then you can click click to open
on that big m I button on the
left.
Oh, right. Yep.
And then it's gonna begin opening that cluster
itself directly to your Lens desktop application.
Remember guys,
it's only read access initially, so he will
not be able to perform specific functions. That's
why he doesn't see the Prometheus.
Let's see if you can even take a
look at the nodes.
I'm curious. It does show you.
But if you tried to do any admin
functions here,
like drain the node or shell into the
pod or something along these lines You feeling
brave?
Try it.
Dreads.
Well, excellent.
So,
as you guys can see,
we
shared a space with David and,
added that cluster to that space, and now
he had access to that cluster itself,
which is so, so cool. Yeah. He can
view some of the resources, some of the
pods, some of the objects here, but he
won't be able to perform anything that can
scare us. See if you can view the
logs, David.
On the top right.
Yeah. There it is. Yeah. One over. Yep.
Nope. I don't think so.
Okay.
We don't have any, I guess.
Or or that could be the case. Yeah.
What are we looking at?
WordPress.
It looks like your WordPress is finally happy.
Now?
Think it's didn't wanna be.
Yeah. Hold on. Let's see. Let's
see. I'm curious.
It's the spinning wheel of death. When that
happens on my MacBook, I wanna cry sometimes.
Yeah. Maybe I don't have permissions to set
up a port forward.
Exactly.
Exactly. I am actually releasing a blog where
I have a guide on how to give
new permissions directly to
a user that wants it for for their
specific space. Oh, you can use the logs.
Yes. NGINX doesn't have any logs, but the
WordPress app definitely does seem to have some.
So there we go.
That's cool.
So this is your local cluster on your
own machine that you're sharing to me via
Lenspaces.
Exactly.
Yeah. Exactly. And, again, that's done by cluster
connect,
which is an end to end encryption that
creates that tunneling that that we talked about
already.
What kind of technology is the tunnel using?
Something like WireGuard?
That's actually an excellent question, the FireFlash.
I don't have that answer for you right
now, and I apologize for that. I do
know it's a Damian set, but I do
not know exactly what the technology is itself.
But you can access
the open source technology, which is called BoardD.
It's created by Team Lens, and you can
actually
spin this up on your own. So it
doesn't have to be used for Lenspaces.
So I know that doesn't answer your question,
and I apologize for that, but you can
access four d
and just grab it and be able to
actually create this similar experience without Lenspaces.
I tried to edit your surface, but I
got permission to find.
Dang. Good.
Good.
I like I like that. Lens spaces is
pretty nice. That was well, it was seamless.
Just opening up Yeah. It's joining it and
then poking around like a very curious rabbit,
but very nice.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And this is something that
I think,
many
of us may have troubles with, whether you're
a cluster admin or a developer needing access
to to a QConfig file. Because we're never
giving you access to the QConfig file. Right?
You're getting access to that space. And based
off of the RBAC and the role bindings,
you can give them further access to that
cluster,
which is super, super useful. And, as mentioned,
I am releasing a blog, either today or
tomorrow.
It'll be on my Medium channel and on
Team Lens where I actually have a guide
on how to give the correct role bindings,
let's say, for a developer that wants to
access,
a Kubelet namespace or something along these lines
or a default namespace or whatever the namespace
may be,
and a specific team.
So one thing we didn't take a look
at here is I just added you as
a member, but you can actually create a
team within that space, and then that team
will be given specific
permissions
based again off that role binding that we
would do, to the KubeConfig file itself.
So
you're just a member right now, but if
I created a team for developers and then
I added that particular
command line and that snippet, that code itself,
I can easily give you
specific access to namespaces and so forth, whatever
functions you're trying to perform to that cluster.
So we're seeing many users, leveraging this for,
let's say, for example, viewing logs of microservices
or applications and so forth so forth. Right?
So extremely useful, and I think we all
know how challenging
sharing access to a Kubernetes cluster may be.
Viral, VPNs,
air gap tunneling, all these different parameters
that we need to jump through in the
hoop hoop. So this is why we develop
Length Spaces because we're hoping that it actually
helps
our users and the cloud native ecosystem.
Nice. Very, very cool. I like this a
lot.
So well,
it looks like we got a comment. Maybe
it's from someone on your team, Ty Martin?
I've never met Tai Martin. No. So but
that's agent's model is an outbound connection to
the Spaces service, which works as a secure
proxy. That is correct. Yes.
There we go. Thank you, Tai.
Is there a favorite place to search for
extensions? Absolutely, Daniel. So
the best way to access extensions is actually
what I showcased. So if you just go
to the Lens application,
go to that extensions,
icon, it will link you directly to,
all of the publicly made available extensions that
Team Lens has vetted of being safe.
This first line. We have another question by
Russell. I'll take a look at this. Can
Lens compare clusters? Example, a Teams test versus
live clusters to highlight differences.
No. I I do not believe we can
do that. No. But that's actually
really good feedback, and I'm going to take,
note of this if you guys don't mind,
because that's actually super interesting. Thanks for pointing
that out, Russell. But, no, we can't do
that as a right mark. That's first line
of authors
highlight a lot of
That's actually a super good idea. And and,
Kai, I also wanna thank you for jumping
in and answering that question for me. I
really do appreciate that. Thank you.
Sweet. Awesome.
Well, thank you very much for taking time
out of your day and and joining us
and
showing us all the features of Lens. I
think we can all agree it's a pretty
impressive tool.
I think the extension thing is awesome, and
I'd love to see what people come up
with there. There must be so many random
ideas
bouncing around in people's heads, and I can't
wait to see them. So
Yes. Agreed. Agreed. For example, cube cost has
a great one, which will tell you how
much you're spending on your Kubernetes clusters. Right?
It'll it'll break it down for you and
so forth. I mean, similar to what some
of these public cloud offerings do for us.
Right? But it's very, very cool. It's directly
intertwined with with Lens, and there's many different
extensions. So I agree with you. That's super
awesome. One thing I did wanna do, the
last thing, David, if you don't mind, is
just share a screen with our contact information
where people can find us, if they have
any questions for me, if they have questions
for the team, if they wanna join the
Slack channel, if they wanna receive a hoodie
as well. So Yeah. Go for it. Awesome.
So I'll share my screen one more time,
everybody.
I know we're at an hour now.
And last thing, here's where you can find
Lens.
You can also download it from our website.
There's my email at Morantis. Here's a Lens
email.
And join our Slack community, and feel free
to ping me. Just ping me on Slack
or ask questions on Slack. All of our
team members are there, and some of the
really core developers and contributors to the open
source project are there answering questions day after
day. And if you're interested in a hoodie
depending on where you are in the world,
I'm more than happy to send send you
guys some cool hoodies and swag.
We we want everybody to feel extremely welcome
to the community because, again, we could not
be where we are today without the amazing
cloud native ecosystem.
So thank you all again. And, David, thank
you.
Alright. I will definitely drop those links into
the show notes as well and the description.
So I'll make it easy for everyone to
click, get some information, and get the hoodie.
Alright. Well,
thank you again. Really cool product. Great seeing
that start to finish.
Everyone, go check it out. Let me know
how you get on. Join the Discord, and
I'll speak to you soon. Edward, thanks again.
Have a great day. Okay? You too. Thank
you. Bye bye.